what
okay for people joining this live stream
we are
doing a meeting about incremental
language design for wolfram language
and we have a variety of topics here i
have a suspicion that our topic number
four is kind of the biggest one here but
let's uh
let's try and start off with what we
think are going to be simple
uh topics
okay see the futurised rough page for
nth digit
i wish it didn't read nth like that has
anybody got any idea about how to fix
that
as opposed to
no i mean yeah it just seems so
arbitrary
and um extract digit or something
yeah that might be uh workable
but let's talk about whether it's
extract or um
i mean don't we have some other bit set
bit get
um yeah it's either bit get or bit fetch
bit cut
look what this is it's analogous to part
basically but for digits
um yeah
how can it be the the real number what
do you mean the nth digit
it's the coefficient of of 10 to the n
right
yeah except um no
sorry no uh we've been
taking the convention that the first
digit is left most
um for numbers greater than one greater
or equal to one
and um for numbers it's not
always the the leftmost non-zero digit
no because we we don't do that because
it would be for reals it would mean the
first significant digit
or what depends on what you call
significant
so is point zero zero three one
you know is the three the first
significant zero digit or
or are those zeros counted i don't
remember my significance arithmetic on
that
well and we're counting that we're
counting
that three is the fourth digit so the
first digit is implicitly in the ones
place
the way it's currently coded i don't
like this
actually sounded on a live stream
pointing out that can't real digits be
uh be set up just to have a list three
instead of
three digits like if we say real digits
pi 10 what is that that's
is it pi 10 10 yes
um
you know
in a perfect world we might want to
support some string arguments for real
digits
that allow you to extract pieces of this
mantissa mantissa exponent mass
it's a fourth argument that allows part
of that
i understand that but well okay but i
mean if if i say
10 digits here see i'm still getting
this stuff here
right what i mean is that one can say
start with this one and give me one
and then you get only one effectively
well i understand but it's kind of a
mess because you've still got all this
other junk there
right i'm suggesting that there's a way
that might be yet another argument that
in a more readable way
rather than saying first of real digits
um
the uh um
to uh
um you know to be able to extract this
with with like mantissa or something
i mean i do wonder whether there's a
possibility that we should have
something called like mantissa digits or
some such other thing
is that obviously stupid i mean because
you could do mantissa exponent of pi
okay now you could say now we know
that those digits will just be
maybe this is stupid maybe this is
stupid okay but
let's go back to the to this nth digit i
i i'm not agreeing with this design
i mean to me i think it should be
something that extracts the coefficient
of b to the n
that seems to me to be the useful thing
i mean
sometimes you want look what kinds of
things do you want
one issue is that that will go against
what the
wfr function does which is not deadly or
anything don't count
if we rename it don't care that won't be
called ant digit anyway
this will not be called out to digit um
let's assume that what we have
is okay so let's see bit get
basically is doing that operation isn't
it
the coefficient of two to the k right
right um
so i mean the obvious thing would be to
call it digit get
and have that be the direct analog of
this
it's the coefficient of 10 to the k in
the thing whatever the thing is
introduce real doesn't really matter
and if we say for example digit get
of 34 comma minus four
it's just zero
does that make sense i think this is a
nice clean function
and one that we should have had a long
time ago and if you want to know
okay so it goes along with this family
integer length
34 great it's 2. so that's the maximum
value of the
exponent that i can be asking for here
now i also think that here
i'm a little concerned about the
argument order so
the nth digit the question is with three
arguments should the base go
before or after the um in other words
should it be
digit get of number
comma base comma n eliding down to
number get a
number comma n all right i was muted it
should be
n comma b base is optional
i understand that but i want to know
where it is in other functions
like if you look at integer digits okay
we have things like take largest by
which i think we put n before there look
look guys guys
this is the analog i think
no i don't i don't agree with that okay
all right
what's the length is is more optional
than bass
meaning less likely to be non-default
jose what were you what were you saying
i was thinking of some other functioning
which we have to extract
n and then we have some information so i
was thinking of take largest
by for example we had a similar
discussion of the order
i have to look it up almost every time
um okay what's the name that we should
be using here
is digit gap the right name it's a
little weird
um
extract digit is not outrageous
it has a sudden take your finger out of
the thing
yeah yeah yeah i certainly like it
better
in fact they would even take
what uh well i was i was about to say
that i like you digit get better than
get digit but
i'm not sure i actually do well let's
say
goes along with bit cat i think we're
going to go in that direction
what's another analogous function here
okay so we've got bit set bit clear
bit length
see we've got integer length but what's
nice about digit gat
is that it will work both on reals and
integers
right right
did you get is there any other name that
we can say i mean it's like digit part
um digit
what other things do we have along those
lines
and also how can we imagine enhancing
so is there any good reason why we
shouldn't allow a list of
of digits to get
well well the question is do we want to
be
part like or or take you know
extract light i think we wanted to be
extract like i think we want to give a
range here i don't think you want to
give a span
because it will change the structure you
want to be able to get back a digit
boom i got a digit type thing you see
what i'm saying
rather than a list but if you put in a
list you can get back a list
was taking a um sequence spec
what was sorry the nth digit um
that that we have now is taking a
sequence spec
for that end
yeah it's the third note yeah
i'm not excited about that i think by
the time
well we're changing if we're going to
change it to mean
you know the digit corresponding to 10
to the n
then this would have to change
also but i think it's a reasonable type
of spec to give
well if we're going to give that we
should give it as a span
i i i think it's more useful to give
specific digits
i want the one one three seven digits i
think that's much more useful
right and i think it's digit part or or
digit parts i don't like digit part
because
you know a digit is is an atomic
thing so it's not it's not right it's
not about arguing with what it is so
it's
so it's number part right then right
it's a number part it gives you
we want to get the word digit in there
because it really is a digit
digital part that's rather crazy
then when we're thinking digital oh my
god we've got land
um digits part
i don't think so because you're mostly
going to return a single digit
standalone live stream keeps on
disgusting
integer digit and real digit i don't
like that because i think that
integer digits and real digits are very
commonly used functions
and i think that to have another
function that differs just by one
letter like that but it's much less
commonly used as a mistake we also don't
want
two functions in this case we want no we
don't we just want one and and
number digit number digit could work
number digit is not bad we have all this
other number
more basic number functions like number
expand and number decompose
yeah number digit uh works well in my
mind
then dan ordayne on our live stream is
is um
suggestion just digit i don't like that
because it's it's not a well enough
encrusted
thing it will it'll get to um
i like number digit okay i'm going to
argue again
for the b comma n story
as opposed to n comma b in other words
and danny is going to argue against it
you're just going to force people to
type
10 all the damn no no no no no no no no
no no no that form will be supported and
the three argument form would look like
that
or is that just stupid
i mean i'm not a huge fan of optional
middle arguments
yeah flame here i i know but but the
point is that by the
i think okay so in terms of what it's
going to look like in code
i think the 90 case is going to be
number digit
uh num you know m comma 2 comma i
i think that's going to be the most
common thing you see in code
and to me this just feels right because
it's two to the i
it's the two to the i thing
i think it's right to do it this way
around because i really think this case
is going to be
most common
i'll support it whichever way you know
the code will
sanders is i'm not quite sure i can't
interpret his comment
of whether whether he's saying he hates
this or
oh he's saying he would do 10 all the
time well yeah but you don't have to
type 10 you're just saying
if it's 10 the default base is 10
exactly so number digit of this
is equal to number digit of
uh number comma 10 comma n
i really like seeing the b and n that
way round
just because of the two to the i thing
all right i think number digit is a good
thing it's much better than nth digit
and this is a better design and it will
go perfectly with with uh
you know bit get is a lower level thing
but it will work perfectly with that
so i think we're good there um
we also have a string part which takes
the list and the span
and then we could consider a number part
to be
like the string part of the number as a
string
in some base
well that that goes back to the earlier
design
the current
i i don't think this is the right thing
i think for these numbers
this is a mathematical thing you want
the coefficient of 10 to the n
that's what you want or b to the n and
and the span thing i think is going to
be a minority case
i think i think there are algorithms for
which you want for example the odd
number digits
now the only thing that i would consider
possible
is something where there is a span
where this thing could have a span
and then where that returns a list is
that is that conceivable do we do that
anywhere
to have it return a singleton you know
non-list
and to return a list only when there's a
span i mean clearly we know that if
there's a list there
i i i am pretty sure that's
what uh that's part string part does
and right certainly part right if you
okay fine
fine then we can do that then we then
we're good then we've got all these
different cases
we can do the the um if we want to do it
spanning
we can do it with a span otherwise we're
doing it with um
with explicit elements just like just
like part does
and i think it's called number digit
rather than number part
because it is indexing itself using its
coefficient of b to the n
not or you know not doing it in the
structural way that part does it
i like this design i think this is a
good design
okay yes i agree because with the
negative
obviously with negative oh yeah that
would be absolutely disastrous with
parts with negative part numbers and
things and
and um uh okay hey where am i saving
these um
uh you know maybe i should just start i
have a thing called ilb and i'm just
going to save this in the ild in my ild
folder okay um
so as a topic for lcc do you think
string part should now take a base
that was a joke no but but down on our
live stream makes a very good point
thank you for that comment
they ask i shouldn't say he asked
because i have no idea
they ask um
what do we do if it's um number digit of
number
and then it's the span 27-1
what does that mean
well that means that that means the four
digits from
it does but it's a very weird case of
span
oh yeah usually span wouldn't
allow you to go backwards like that wait
a second
that's not the meaning of spam though
well what what are you saying i mean it
span
what what's not the meaning of span if i
if i were to say a b
you know range of 20
sub sub 2 semi-semi minus
minus 4 for example i get that
yeah that's the correct meaning i
understand that
but in this case minus 1 in number digit
will be the coefficient of ten to the
minus one so we're not using
span in in the sense of an extraction
specification if we do this i know we
thought we were but we're not
and the other problem is that the number
digits are in the opposite order
yeah just about to point that out
in the fact is that um uh
i'm liking span here more uh less and
less
we use span in other places with some
sort of extended
meaning like statistics statistics uses
discrete distributions
how does it where is it in discrete
distribution i'm i'm trying to remember
like domains of discrete distributions
perhaps or something like that
okay but let's just go through one thing
here so so this is
number digit of this comma 1
is the coefficient of 10 to the actually
there's no one there's that should be
zero
yes so this thing here is is well known
as three
okay so let's let's just be clear okay
number digit of one two three
okay comma zero would be three
okay so now if i want to get the
sequence of digits one two three
i mean the natural thing to do if i were
to say span
one to three would be to get the digits
uh two one zero
from this yes
right which i guess is why you in in the
original design that danny proposed
you started indexing one at the left
most
yeah which is crazy and not useful
think it's useful but it i i would see a
different use case
look if you want to do that use integer
digits with the fourth argument
if what you want is the digits right to
the left yeah yeah
but right but when people talk about you
know the 50th digits of pi
they don't think of it as minus 49
right so
i mean did the i'm not our
i'm not saying we we have to slavishly
following
the wfr function but the wfr function is
serving
a real need which yeah
okay
number digit um it is a little weird
that we're calling the the digit first
to the right of the decimal point the
minus one
digit
yeah i mean it's documentable there
there is a good reason to do this i'm
not
arguing that and i think it's too weird
to call it number
number part it's too weird it's a digit
um do we want to have a new convention
where positive values are digits to the
right of the decimal point and negative
absolutely not
well that wait isn't that what we're
proposing
[Music]
now what what's being proposed here is
i reverse left and right as always
no what we're proposing is that the that
this
argument the n here is the coefficient
of b to the n
you are getting out the coefficient of b
to the n in my opinion that is the only
you know that is the only
algorithmically useful thing
in terms of everyday language it is true
you say give me the fourth digit of pi
or something or the or the millionth
digit of pi
okay if you ask the other way around
if you say
do you ever say it for integers what's
the third
yeah you do in benford's law for example
you'd say what's the first digit of blah
blah blah
by which you mean the highest players
look i think number digit is the right
name for this mathematically defined
function
the whole question about getting the
first digit
it is easy to do that with integer
digits it is also easy to get the first
three digits which might also be useful
yeah i think this is the right thing i'm
i'm going ahead with this i'm still
not convinced about this span
i'm not convinced either and i it's uh
thank you to for pointing out that the
two semi minus one
because that's crazy
yeah that that was the most uh i think
the
yeah i was a bit uncomfortable with that
all right so look i i think we should do
this without the span
and um
i don't know how important the span
would be in a sense it's a number
pruning operation
if you have the span there does integer
digits allow you to prune
number prune numbers
that is does if i want to get only the
nth
digit only only every
oh my gosh
um if i want to get only
um
you can't get every other if that's what
you're asking that's what i'm asking and
i
i you know honestly i haven't needed it
very much
it's silly it's silly all right i think
we got a design here
let's go yeah i just right if
you want the the two minus
two through minus one behavior right you
can do range of two minus one minus one
and right if you support lists
sure absolutely you can get that i the
only the only reason is some sort of
efficiency hack
if you're trying to extract a huge
number of digits and i just don't i
don't think that's useful anyway
yeah i mean that's also something we
could add later if we absolutely
yeah right yes moving on guys moving on
i think we got it we got a we got a
solution there
okay great okay batch map by
so we have tony to discuss that yeah
maybe looking at a couple of examples i
put an example in chat early on
and and for example well yeah
i i put an example that was useful for
me
well because i was confused by tony's
examples but
you we can start by looking at tony's
maybe the second one is more useful
you should resend it okay
okay
people are asking how i organize my file
system i actually have written about
that i wrote this giant blog post
giant weird blog post about uh personal
productivity and i do talk about how i
organize my file system i'm on now
i think i'm on the fourth or fifth
generation in my life of file systems of
uh of how i've organized it
but i did write about that um
maybe somebody can put the uh uh the
link in chat
um and i yes of course i've paid a lot
of attention to how it's done
and it does very well i'm able to pull
things up that i did 30 years ago
and i can usually nail them almost
immediately without search
so i'm impressed with myself in that
regard okay let's look at
etai's example oh my gosh
batch map by so is this basically a map
produced story
not really uh oh i guess he has an i
guess you need to run the section
entitled code before it'll work
right so it takes all the things that
are equal
according to the third argument and then
applies a function to that list of
things
and so here i'm i'm mapped
using map index to add a subscript to
each element of the list
of identical things
so but if i were to say same queue there
it's identical is it a buy function yes
it's a buy function so if i say
i mean the i see the a's are considered
identical there
so if i would say for example here if i
would have in this list range of
100 and i were to say prime q here right
what i would get is
right so all the primes have increasing
subscripts and then all of the
non-primes have increasing subscripts
right and the reason we care about this
is that that's not
that's the thing that's not so clear to
me so maybe tony can explain
why we care about this yes
so the the idea is that you have a long
list that you want to process
efficiently
but you have an evaluator that can only
take
um lists that are equal that have
elements that are similar in some sense
yeah and further down below there's an
example
now with a few entities and a few
external identifiers you know
and you want to get the images and it is
efficient to
get the images for all entities in one
call and also for
all those external identifiers in one
call
and so you want to process those subsets
efficiently
yeah and then put them back in the right
order
yes all right so basically the point
here
let's see what we can by the way whoever
remembers the relative precedence of
these various functional operators
we we so desperately need um some kind
of
you know ghosted brackets here when you
move over this but hopefully we're
getting that soon
or maybe somebody else has a has a great
way to remember these precedences
these are substantivities okay but but
the basic point here
is
batch map by the right name for it
i think
what does batch apply to do
it's it's a proposed wrapper that we
haven't implemented yet
that would wrap a function inside
map and related constructs so that it
receives
all of the arguments at once and that
would be useful in
functions like select where you want to
where you can
efficiently compute the condition for
multiple elements at once
i see so so in the case that we'd say
that we'd say
select range of a million
uh and then we'd say
what would we say here we'd say batch
applied
how would this work and then some
listable function that returns
a list of booleans
say prime queue and this oh yeah i mean
this is definitely something i've wanted
to do many times i mean i do this
usually what i do is i do it with pick
usually what i end up saying is i say
pick and then i say something like um
from range of ten to the six
that's not two ten to the sixth let's do
ten to the three
and then let's say pick
i'm sorry i did the pick there then i
say prime q
slash at range of ten to the three
right okay so so i mean what's the
difference between
the the first input or that and just
select the range of 10 to the six
comma prime q prime q is going to be
evaluated a million times
and but supply will just i mean
steven for example could have just said
prime prime q of
range right get rid of the
get rid of the slash exactly
yeah exactly right but i i'm i'm going
to object to the
to the batch map by i mean why isn't the
subset
mapped by i mean we have subset map
which i think
is doing the similar thing only it's not
grouping with the third argument so this
seems to me like a subset
map by yes that was another proposal for
name
because it's so similar which thing the
batch map by
yes
okay yeah it has a feeling like subset
map
also like gathered by
but subset map you have to tell it
the subset that you are mapping onto
right and here the the role of the
subset is place is played
by these gather groups
so i think batch map by can be thought
also as the second alternative wording
says as gathering
the elements then mapping and then
reinserting as
subset map would do i see i say i see i
see
i see i see
so the whole point is so you can think
of this subset map
it extracts that subset it does its
operation and
it stuffs it back in the list which is
exactly what this is doing
right
okay and the whole
it's really the the only issue is it is
it is subsetting by the by function
so to speak exactly
and there's no way to indicate that in
subset map itself
subset map is positional what was your
analogy with gather
does gather have a positional mechanism
too no but the first step
of of subs of batch map by is to
group together the elements that obey
the that have the same value of buy
exactly
which is good what gathered by does
right i see
or goodbye no i'm just wondering is
there a third argument for subset map
there isn't because this is a
multi-subset well no
subset map allows you to do it at
multiple
sets of positions doesn't it
yes the third argument can be uh
sets of positions
that's not documented here is it
oh sorry no no no what i mean is
is it can be a list of positions not
just a list of indices
so so the post can be a list like
extract
no i understand but what if you want to
but the whole point about
this new function is that every element
of the list
oh i see what you mean so the f will be
mapped on different groups will be
applied to different groups rather than
a single group like subset map
i have a question what happens if i want
to do subset map on multiple subsets
at a time right
we are not prepared for that but we
could yeah
it will require another level of list
um
but that's is that inconsistent with the
extract usage
no there isn't exact usage there isn't
one because these
there's no depth in in the exper
you're not going are you and saying
takes f to be a length and sub list of
lists
right it's yes we should do that
we should allow a list of multiple
and essentially we should fold together
the subset maps
of multiple it so it's like a folded
subset map
right
okay oh yeah if we did a folded subset
map
then this thing so one of the issues is
if we had subset map by how do we
exclude an element from being
you know in other words you're you're
saying they're these
things that are considered to be the
subsets but what if you don't want
something in a subset at all
you say missing or something for its
subset name
because you're indirectly naming the
subsets here that's what the third
argument is doing
yes so
any function could just have a fallback
value that
returns the list unchanged
i i don't understand that but i don't
understand
i'm saying don't even put it like with
subset map
you're picking out certain elements
doing the
operation on them and stuffing them back
in the list
right
and i'm saying i'm saying what if you
don't want to stuff
okay with subset map you're picking out
only particular elements to apply the
function to and stuffing the result of
that back in the list
but what i'm saying is that there's a
hole between these two
right so subset map i could with a
folded version of subset map i could
list
all kinds of different pieces of the
list but there might be things not
listed and then they simply wouldn't
have the f applied to them
whereas in this other case you're saying
use
same queue i mean you've essentially got
another argument which is the same test
for when to buy
two elements that map to the same thing
under buy
should actually be grouped together
what is this thing at the end of the day
it is doing it is like
saying gather by
yeah the big issue the big difference is
this is reconstituting the original list
in its original order
yes so it might be similar to a subset
map
by where we have an additional argument
the by function
which would be similar to an additional
argument the gathering
yes and instead of an explicit list of
positions we might allow
all in the case that we want to apply to
all
i'm sorry you're saying change subset
map to have an additional buy argument
yes or have a new function that's called
subject map by
which defaults to having all as
the the set of things on which it acts
yes i think this requires a bit more
thought
and and let's understand the use case
um
uh i mean the use case that you have
here
is you've got an operation that is
conveniently done
in a batch mode to a subset of the
elements in a list
gosh is anybody going to understand this
i'm thinking of a situation in which for
example i have in geo lots of
entities polygons points etc and i want
to do something
to all of them together but different
groups
yes mean essentially it's a map
operation it's a pure map operation
with
some kind of listable grouping of
elements
i mean honestly the name batch map by
does suggest more what the point is
why you would ever do this
because you do this because
i mean in the end
i don't know whether the function that
you give is itself going to be a map
onto each of these individual things but
it probably is something more like a
just a listable operation
right tony i mean your versions here use
entity value which is essentially a
listable operation
yes
yeah i think that's important like in
subset that the function needs to return
something of the same length
people are saying here what under they
don't understand subset map subset map
was a difficult
function to um design
and and i think it does have the right
name i think it's
it's um it is taking a subset
doing something to that subset and
putting that subset back in the list
um sorry so that again what you did
jose you just made another comment um um
i was comparing to subset maps saying
that it's important that the function f
takes lists and returns lists of the
same length
right i mean the main point here is
reconstituting it in the right order
which doesn't always matter i mean in
some of your geo-rendering type things
you could just pick up
do all the polygons do all this to all
of that and they can be in their own
order so to speak and they could just be
grouped by being whether they're
polygons and things
if i'm making sense and you could just
separately deal with each of those lists
the point here is preserving the
original order
yes so so that's the only reason for
that function
for for all the other cases where the
order doesn't matter we already have
those covered i think you need more use
cases
and the fact that you have to write such
a complicated piece of code
to get it to even make sense down there
on the last line
is not encouraging
i mean maybe there's a different
solution to that problem if the problem
there really
is that entity value has a different
i i think that's a put up job what you
have there i'd like to see some other
examples
in the meantime certainly batch map buy
will be a fine function repository
function but i think it requires more
thought
i'm not convinced about this one uh
meanwhile we had a question from sandra
on the live stream asking
what will number digit do if the
precision is gone basically
and that's a good question so in other
words what will happen
if what are we going to do what are we
going to return
if number digit is given something which
is out of digits i mean what do we
return
we have that crazy what is it called
number what is the thing called where
you can actually get all the bits in a
number
what is that thing called
come now somebody here knows the answer
know what you mean
i would use real digits in base two
okay what happens if i ask for real
digits
so i think what danny implemented is
returning indeterminate for those digits
okay okay there we go so that's the
answer
that's the answer that's what you would
return in this case do people agree
about this
i think it's the only consistent thing
to do yep yep
okay all right onward
for a minute rate limiting of echo
okay so
what i was looking for was
a way that i can put echo in my code but
if it's gonna generate a thousand echoes
or
a hundred thousand echoes i don't wanna
see them all how do i do that
so in other words in some sense i want
that
one instance of echo to
record how many times it has been used
in a given inline
just like messages and stop them
stop itself see what i'm saying
right so so we were thinking that this
is easier to control from outside some
function that wraps the whole expression
and takes care of
things from outside because how do you
know which echoes are the same i mean
the distinguishability of echoes yeah
no i understand but what i'm suggesting
is we do the same thing that confirm and
close
does and look lexically tag the echoes
because each echo basically needs an id
once you know the id of that echo once
once a particular echo
that appears in a particular place in
the source code
has an id seventh you know a uuid let's
say
right the echo is given a uuid so in
other words
you're just like confirming close i
don't know exactly what the id is what
the
what are the hidden tags of confirming
close does anybody know
what they actually are do you understand
the mechanism first of all
so for example in a case like that in
which there is a single echo
and then a table to consider that the
same one
i do let me give you the rule right but
but confirming close certainly doesn't
right can what confirm and close does is
if that f had you know
seven you know seven different echoes
that would
say okay these are the seven echoes
inside of me
but let's sir if you if f calls g
and g has an uh confirm inside of it
you know that's that's different
look confirming close in by default
works lexically
so it can confirm
only jumps to its
lexically enclosing enclosed by default
isn't that correct
right and that that so these echoes are
not lexically enclosed
right they're they're only lexically
enclosed by f
um i think i understand the idea of
enclosing but what is the enclosing
function for echo
uh
well i assume it's the inline i mean i
assume it's it's just the top level
by the way an interesting suggestion
here from ethan um
in rate limiting echo a way to send the
rest of the echoes for example to the
messages window
or to somewhere else
interesting potential idea i mean
and sandra is suggesting the very simple
idea of a dollar echo limit
that's something that doesn't respect
all of them right
yeah that would just apply within a
given into outline
just the total number of echoes that can
happen
i mean that's certainly a simple
approach right
not sure what i would necessarily set it
to
i'm sorry let me continue with this this
localized thing because i really
it really would be very nice to
replicate our messages behavior with
echoes
that is you know the same echo only gets
to be applied end times
now what do you do in this case is it
the same echo or not
boy it's like is it the same photon
after it gets absorbed and re-emitted
exactly because the message i mean you
can have the same message written in
three places
and they will count all together it's
like once i mean you can have right
because because it's by
by by head and tag right
so if you have different heads or
different tags you might see the message
more than three times
but it's by wait a minute it's by
head globally within that in-out cycle
right head and tag yeah i understand the
particular of the message
and so the analog of the tag here is
what the lexical content of the echo is
so lexically there is a hash of that
thing which is what that is echoing
that's like the tag
right but but if i but if i have you
know
if i have an echo
of res three times in my function
yeah yeah you don't want to merge them
all you don't want to merge them
i agree so
the correct version
i would claim the analog of a tag is the
lexical place where the echo appears
in other words if if it was something
like you know if we had line numbers and
things
it would be that echo that appears on
line 472.
now if the echo is dynamically created
at runtime you're out of luck
am i making sense
now okay so given that the tag
okay so look the thing that i would like
to see is between
any two in out labels that the number of
times that a particular lexically
specified echo
is used is limited
is that a doable thing so
each echo as it appears lexically
at well if there's no
it doesn't like enclose which which
actually goes looking
lexically for its corresponding confirm
just like module goes looking lexically
for its corresponding uh variables
what looks lexically for the for the
echo
and then what happens if there's an echo
for some sub function yeah this is not
going to work
lexical like that is not going to work
because think about it the sub function
that you already defined many cells ago
is not being re-scanned when you're
doing the when you're initiating the
evaluation someplace else
making sense so my lexical idea is just
not going to fly
so then a dollar echo limit does seem
not completely unreasonable
um
is there any way that a
assume that every echo in the system had
a uuid
yeah i don't understand why this
wouldn't work i mean assume every echo
has an implicit uuid okay so it has
it's a you know echo of blah
comma echo
id arrow uh
you know some random thing like this
okay
that every echo as soon as it's parsed
gets that thing
are making sense and then what happens
is there's a global table
in the repel that basically says how
many times has each echo id
been seen
when you say past do you mean
uh i mean i think this has to be at the
valuation time
but um yeah i don't know
i mean how can parsons add a uuid
well okay the question is how can
um
could we reuse the labels of the echo
you say we put labels and then from
outside we say for this label
allow three times
that the evaluated or unevaluated label
evaluated label you're saying echo
constrained or something
yeah or ian's idea of of reducing quiet
echo
in a sense quiet eco is like not
allowing anyone
so it would allow a few
i yeah possibly
but you're saying we can't tag the
echoes
i find difficult that echo at evaluation
time suddenly develops
its own i don't think it can work at
evaluation time it's it's got to be the
case that echo
how does it store itself in that form if
at paris time
echo added an echo id then
all it has to do with evaluation time is
compare this to a global table
you know inside the rapple basically
that says
have i you know has this echo id been
seen too many times inside this
this in out cycle
well to have presence of of addition of
those uuids
at parts time again no do you have any
presence of this addition of
a uuid at part time no we don't
no we don't and we also don't have a way
oh boy i mean we're getting more of
these kinds of things as we look at code
assistance we're getting more
information
about where a particular function
appeared
in the in kind of in the source
i think this is not um uh
yeah i mean look the echo limit or echo
constrained are both
reasonably um victoria's suggesting echo
few and hans is commenting the same idea
was echoed in a previous
uh one of these design sessions i'm uh
we should check that
have we discussed echo we we have
discussed echo before for echo function
and so on
um all right the idea of limiting echo
has appeared before
and for example we were also discussing
limiting by rate so only three per
second
things like that but i think the main
problem is the same that in my opinion
we need a wrapper function from outside
like a monitor echo
it could decide i'm going to group all
together and then report
a digest something at the end or
something
i see echo handler right
something that exactly something from
outside
then it will be powerful and maybe we
can get both things by having a dollar
echo limit that is the default that's a
global default
that's what would its value be
a few hundred and i would start with
infinity and then if you want to limit
it you have to set it
no but the case that i see so often it's
like the too big
output type thing you don't know it's
going to happen until it happens
and when it happens you're upset but
when it's sprinting
lots of echoes you can abort it if you
don't want right
so i don't see a problem in that
it would be more problematic the other
way like oh i
just missing the one i was interested in
and you have to repeat the operation
fair point point
all right more thought um there was an
an echo meeting was on december 20th
night 2020 okay we need the notes from
it
um
right and i i just put an example in
chat just so we're all clear
on what lexically you know what the
lexical scanning of
of confirming and close are
right so that enclosed doesn't see the
confirm that's inside th
because it's not lexically inside of
exactly
right so you know so if we had
you know we could have a you know an
echo handler but that would only
it won't it's not useful it's not useful
because because what you want to do with
echo
is so often non-local yeah
um
somebody's commenting we're missing the
starship test flight i don't know what
that is
obviously we're missing it whatever it
is what are we missing
i don't know
we have billy to discuss the
design okay very quickly and then then i
need to i'm actually supposed to be
doing another live stream
uh very soon oh spacex is doing
a starship test flight
okay hopefully elon is having fun with
it
um
now i am curious what that thing
actually is
oh
right whatever yes
it's cool
um okay
all right what are we seeing here we're
seeing this is designs
for okay this is ugly
so that was the original thing we were
we had
long ago and these are the new ideas
okay with their green box etc
okay
i like that color
i kind of think we should be i mean
do we like this yellow and if we're
going to use that box color don't we
want to reflect that somehow here
and that's what you're suggesting with
this but i don't think that's not what
we do we don't reflect
now i'm arguing against myself we don't
reflect the purple
color of a
graph box in the graph itself
right um
what's this here oh that's a that's a a
subtree
right that's a three payload
why are we using this yellow this is our
entity yellow why are we using the same
yellow
i don't know where this comes from um
do you know believer
last time we talked about trees being
green and that's exactly what we have
here
it's a nice green actually changing
based on season
no that is how to say let us say
one of those absolutely user confusing
things
that would just be unbelievable like
like the thing the thing turns brown and
then we
geo you know we do geolocation and it
would work differently in the southern
hemisphere
that's one of those just imagine the
documentation for some feature like that
um okay i'm not convinced
about these yellows i don't know where
they came from
billy do you have a different suggestion
for a color palette for this
uh there was uh earlier
mock that uh maybe
had a little bit too much that this kind
of paired down into this
if you scroll down a little
under extras
oh yeah i don't think i've seen these
full green seems i mean we don't want
something which looks like the color
means something it's just an accent
color
if that makes sense yeah
and what are all these things with
dotted lines and so on
just different treatments
treatment ideas
and you know these trees could end up
with pretty big things in their payloads
or entities
um
oh i see entities could be in those
nodes which would be yellow and yellow
right where else do we have
a i mean in a
graph what happens when we have named
nodes in a graph
i should know this because i do it all
the time oh i see the typical vertex
label goes outside of the node
right the node color is just some
boring rather unpleasant eye i think
grayish
blue
but the difference here is the node
labels are right in the nodes by default
right i think we were trying to follow
three form in that respect
and perhaps that's where the yellow
comes from yes but i don't think it's
worth following
um all right so this is a rare case
similar to entity where we're putting
content but in this case it's arbitrary
expressions on a background color
right that's a rare case because most
other things like text genographic
whatever it just sits there it doesn't
have it isn't it isn't backgrounded
but in this case we have to background
it because it is being connected to
other things
and we're not choosing in graphs
to put vertex labels by default you can
place them
on a vertex but
notice that in a graph the placement
is it's incredibly boring the background
color
and i need to
go because i'm about i think that's is
that the default that's the default
there
it's not my favorite and i think that's
too dark it's probably something else we
should look at
but that's what we're comparing this to
possibly we should lighten that up and
it should be a much lighter version of
this incredibly boring gray
grayish blue thing
it's a question from harry about
accessibility yes that's a separate team
that tries to look at that
we come up with something and then they
tell us why it's bad
um
that's what i would suggest is that we
try and go we try and lighten this up
and i don't see why the trees color
should be different here from the graph
color what do you think
well i think it's important that users
understand very quickly
that this is different all right fair
enough fair enough okay well slightly
different hue
perhaps but i think we're going to be
changing
tree form to match whatever we do for
tree
fine keep that in mind
yep i mean i think these colors are very
attractive
and there should be a plot theme that
gives them but i think the default has
to be something much more bland
but with some kind of accent color so
maybe what happens is
the the trees go to some kind of your
your kind of
uh whatever it was teal-ish
uh you know background color for the
lynx
maybe maybe although keep it
it's got to be kept dark enough that you
can actually see it when the trees get
big
all right this is going to be a further
discussion and i have to go
and do another live stream about
completely different topic
um
and uh hold on one second
um yes i'm
going to be talking about business and
innovation q a
um that's a sort of recreational topic
as opposed to this which is actual
uh day job work um
okay i think we're going to have to come
back to this we've clearly got quite a
bit more
um uh he's asking about
where we have information about
accessibility i i don't know actually i
we we've um uh um
it's been an ongoing effort and we've
we've done lots of work on it over the
years lots and lots and lots of work on
it over the years
um some some of it is really hard
uh particularly things like speaking uh
expressions and so on we've done a bunch
of work on and it's really hard
um but uh
uh maybe somebody knows where it is and
can put a link i'm sure there is a place
because it's relevant for
all sorts of regulatory compliance
issues and so on
um okay i think we should wrap for now
and i know we have a bunch more to
discuss about trees
um okay
and uh yeah oh boy
is there is a lot of really horrifying
stuff here or is it is are things going
okay in terms of this design
uh we started the this discussion last
week and and it's one of the main
open points the the do we map to trees
or to payloads
or how do we specify one or the other
let's pick it up another time
okay um all right talk to you all soon
thank you all